nicolas de leurs aimiez directeur des
opérations à cette grosse déception
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui
adore aller chez vous d'abord et à tous
les autres chutes dans tous les autres
cas qui pourront pas cette année
effectivement c'est un désastre ap quand
on l'a appris ce midi en même temps
qu'il ya en même temps que tout le monde
d'une manière aussi un peu on est
pauvres non compris dans le point de
presse qu est ce qu est le premier
ministre ni demandée est un peu vague
puis on ne sut ensuite par communiqué
que vraiment nous demander de fermer
toutes les camps de vacances
nous on a la chance aucun de schiste
d'avoir également un cadeau sur le site
ce qui nous permet d'espérer une
ouverture mais comme l'a mentionné éric
beauchemin de l'accord d'association
défense il va falloir que ça vienne avec
un soutien financier parce que ça nous
demande énormément de modifications de
nos services nous précisions pour donnez
moi votre exemple à qui ça appartient
combien de liquidités vous avez quelques
quelle est la situation financière du
cac bruchési par exemple pour nous le
quinze jours ça correspond à 15 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires annuel qui fait
que déjà on a perdu les sorties
scolaires qui venait au monde n'est plus
au mois de juin en ce moment on voit le
tien est complètement vide
il y aurait eu aujourd'hui 300 enfants
qui a été sur le fil et les sorties
scolaires correspond au tour de 25 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires
la colonie de vacances va aller chercher
le reste ce qui fait que le on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec l'annoncé du
gouvernement avoir perdu pas loin de 70
% 75 % des dossiers d'affaires leur est
concédé groupe qui est menée par ci par
là pour profiter de nos services qu'une
nos installations
mais encore là on n'a aucune nouvelle de
ce côté là on sait pas si on doit les
recevoir avec ce soit en septembre en
octobre ou en novembre
comme tout le monde et à qui appartient
la caisse que le groupe a les poches
profondes ou au contraire j'étais un
groupe à but non lucratif comme on dit
puis que vous n'avez pas besoin d'argent
que vous exactement le bon nous on a une
situation particulière ça s'équivaut
dans plusieurs organisations
le cadre choisi nous on est locataire
sur le compte des propriétaires ce qui
fait que on a quand même un loyer à
payer à la propriétaire continuer à
investir sur les bâtiments à préparer
les sites des soupes comme ici ça
pratiquement un mois préparé avant de
pouvoir avoir une ouverture effective en
scène des coups qu'on va devoir nous
débourser sous forme de loyer auprès de
notre propriétaire là on a au moins au
niveau fédéral des mesures d'allègement
de loyer mais encore là c'est parfait ça
vient tout juste d'être d'être annoncée
il faut qu'on se conforment
on n'a pas vraiment de nouvelles à
savoir est ce que ces mesures ne vont
être allongés après pour l'été avec le
nerf de la guerre vraiment pour les
camps de vacances les cadeaux en ce
moment ci finance y est ce que vous
auriez pu par ailleurs bon ça sera pas
le cas mais auriez vous pu organiser les
choses pour recevoir quand même des
petits et des moins petit pour autour du
feu de camp dans lac etc
oui c'est sûr que je peux juste parler
pour mon organisation je peux pas parler
pour l'ensemble des camps de vacances
nous on considère ici contre le ch ez
ont été extrêmement bien outillés pour
les recevoir parce que à la base le camp
avait été fondé au début des années des
années 30
justement pour répondre entre les matic
de santé publique qui est une épidémie
de tuberculose chez les enfants avec nos
espaces quand ils ont été construit et
conçu avec déjà les mesures de
distanciation physique en tête avaient
déjà des espaces où on ne pouvait pas se
croiser sur le site ce qui fait qu'on a
déjà nous un bon une bonne longueur
d'avancé sur bien des organisations qui
mène à limite les écoles pour se
préparer parce que le site a été conçu
en ce sens le bon évidemment les mesures
sanitaires ont changé avec le camp puis
à l'époque ont accueilli 600 enfants ici
au début du siècle début des années 30
le nous avec les calculs qu'on a qu'on
avait fait on comptait en espérait pour
en accueillir 90 à 110 enfants pour
l'été mais évidemment comme le avec
l'annoncé qui est aujourd'hui ça sera
pas posée est-ce qu'un terminal vous
avez pu plaider auprès de quelqu'un ce
que vous avez ce que vous n'êtes
m'expliquer sur les installations parce
que quelqu'un a entendu ça quelque part
non non puis on a depuis le début de la
crise on a envoyé des messages on
envoyer notre candidature partout sur je
contribue en fait un cv pour le
cambrésis a dit envoyez nous des enfants
et outillés pour lire savoir on est
capable de faire
on ne parlait on envoyait des
communications aux différents ministères
on n'a pas eu de retour ou ce nom me
transférer
on n'a pas eu de communication des
répétitions que moi
ce que j'aimerais demander c'est au delà
de l'aspect financier oui on a besoin de
soutien financier mais on a besoin que
certaines organisations pour certains
sites comme le cambrésis plus être
regardée à la loupe
peut-être individuellement pour leur
permettre d'ouvrir avec des conditions
lorsque adaptés à leur réalité l on va
poser la question parce qu'effectivement
puis je pense que personne peut rester
insensible devant ce genre d'arguments
d'autant plus que le bienfait pour les
jeunes qui pas chez vous que ce soit
deux jours ou une semaine est incroyable
il s'en souvienne pour la vie nicolas de
grigny merci on va se reparler merci
merci beaucoup